This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Brit Young is a Geographer and Tech Writer based in the Bay Area, and she loves a good theme party. My whole life, I've done some silly themed parties. And when she says silly, she's not exaggerating. Producer Vivian Le. She told me about a party she threw once based on an obscure sitcom about a rural Canadian farming community. She also used to host annual ragers in honor of Billy Maes,
这里是99% Invisible，我是罗曼·马尔斯。布里特·杨是一位居住在湾区的地理学家和科技作家，她非常喜欢举办主题派对。我这辈子举办过不少傻里傻气的主题派对。当她说“傻里傻气”时，她可一点都没夸张。制作人薇薇安·勒告诉我，她曾经举办过一场派对，主题是一部关于加拿大农村农业社区的冷门情景喜剧。她过去还经常举办年度狂欢派对，以纪念比利·梅斯，
you know, that guy from the Oxie Clean infomercials. Roman Mars here for 99PI. But a few years ago, she threw her wildest party yet. It was an arm party. Brit has what's called a congenital upper limb deficiency. In other words, she was born without the part of her arm just below her left elbow. This latest celebration was a farewell to her boring old prosthesis and a welcome home to her brand new multi-articulating
你知道的，就是那个推销“奥克西清洁剂”（OxiClean）电视购物广告的人。我是99PI的罗曼·马尔斯。但几年前，她举办了有史以来最疯狂的派对。那是一场“手臂派对”。布里特患有先天性上肢缺失症。换句话说，她出生时左肘以下的手臂部分缺失。这次最新的庆祝活动是为了告别她那无聊的旧假肢，并欢迎她那全新的多关节
bionic hand. We had a friend who played bartender and we had a bunch of armed themed cocktails. There was Armageddon, Pink Armadillo, a bunch of things like that. There were also armed themed games like Arm Twister, which was normal Twister, but anytime that you needed assistance, you could grab a free prosthetic arm to reach yellow five easier or whatever. She even christened the high-tech arm by cutting a cake with it. I'm really trying to be sure to pay this to please tweet it.
仿生手。我们请了一位朋友担任调酒师，还准备了一系列以“手臂”为主题的鸡尾酒。有“世界末日”（Armageddon）、“粉红犰狳”（Pink Armadillo）之类的酒。还有以手臂为主题的游戏，比如“手臂扭扭乐”（Arm Twister），玩法和普通的“扭扭乐”一样，但每当你需要帮助时，你可以抓起一只免费的假肢手臂，更容易地够到黄色5号位或者其他什么位置。她甚至用这只高科技手臂切蛋糕，以此为它举行了“洗礼”。我真的在努力确保把这个发到推特上。
And this is not going to work. Here we go, yeah, yeah, yeah. You cut back. You're just opened. You're just so bent. Um, that's the, that's the, uh, what's it called? It's a fist. This is the sound of Brett giving the little demo of how her prosthetic hand works over Zoom. We ended up playing sort of a game of cyborg charades while she cycled through the different grip modes of her prosthesis.
这招行不通。开始了，耶，耶，耶。你切回去。你刚打开。你弯得太厉害了。嗯，那个是，那个是，呃，叫什么来着？那是拳头。这是布里特通过Zoom演示她的假肢手如何工作的声音。我们最后玩了一场“赛博格猜词游戏”，她轮流展示了假肢的不同抓握模式。
I call this one the Obama talking point. It's the thumb resting on top of the index finger and you're like, so you go over, yes. This one might be like, I am a sophisticated cyborg and I am handing you my credit card. And so this one is like Italian. This prosthetic hand has a sleek carbon fiber casing with specific pre-programmed
我把这个叫做“奥巴马谈话要点”。大拇指放在食指上面，就像这样，所以你过去，是的。这个可能就像是，“我是一个精致的赛博格，我正在递给你我的信用卡”。而这个就像是意大利手势。这只假肢手有一个光滑的碳纤维外壳，带有特定的预编程
grips that she can control just by flexing the muscles in her residual limb. She can use a precision pinch to pick a hairpin up off the table or a hulk style power fist to squeeze objects. This kind of assistive technology has been life-changing for a lot of people who have limb differences. But for Britain, in particular, it hasn't been life-changing at all. In fact, her cutting edge bionic arm has been a pretty major disappointment. It's just not what you imagine. It's not like, well, I'm like everyone else now.
抓握模式，她只需弯曲残肢中的肌肉就能控制。她可以使用精密捏合动作从桌上捡起发夹，或者使用绿巨人式的强力拳头来挤压物体。这种辅助技术对许多肢体差异人士来说是改变生活的。但对布里特来说，它并没有带来什么改变。事实上，她那尖端的仿生手臂是一个相当大的失望。它并不是你想象的那样。它不像是在说，“好吧，我现在和大家一样了”。
It's something different. It's something different. The early known prosthesis is actually a wooden toe that dates back to ancient Egypt. But while we've had prosthetics forever, we've only seen major advancements in their design in the last couple hundred years. Mostly thanks to the military. Their development is intricately, intimately, inextricably tied to the military. This is David Sirlin, associate professor of communication in science studies at UC San Diego. He says that the first major leap in prosthetics came after the Civil War,
它是不同的。它是不同的。已知最早的假肢实际上是一根可以追溯到古埃及的木制脚趾。虽然我们使用假肢已经很久了，但我们只在过去几百年里看到了它们设计上的重大进步。这主要归功于军队。它们的发展与军队有着错综复杂、密不可分、不可分割的联系。这是加州大学圣地亚哥分校传播与科学研究副教授大卫·瑟林。他说，假肢领域的第一个重大飞跃出现在内战之后，
which was considered the first modern war. The scale of damage from weapons was unprecedented, and so people hadn't really seen what prosthetics could do on kind of the scale that they would soon come to understand. By the end of the war, tens of thousands of soldiers suffered amputations and needed help
那场战争被认为是第一场现代战争。武器造成的破坏规模是前所未有的，所以人们并没有真正见过假肢在他们即将理解的那种规模下能发挥什么作用。战争结束时，成千上万的士兵遭受了截肢，需要帮助
getting back to their lives. In response, the federal government began subsidizing artificial limbs for union soldiers and prosthetic companies sprang up to meet the spike in demand. In the process, available prosthetic technology for both veterans and civilians grew exponentially. Prosthesis evolved from rudimentary wooden peg legs to artificial limbs that had hinges at the ankles and knees to reproduce a natural gate. Then decades later, World War II led to even more prosthetic innovation. Engineering science, material science, those are all percolating in the 30s and 40s, and they
回归他们的生活。作为回应，联邦政府开始为联邦军士兵补贴人工肢体，假肢公司如雨后春笋般涌现，以满足激增的需求。在此过程中，退伍军人和平民可用的假肢技术呈指数级增长。假肢从原始的木制假腿演变为在脚踝和膝盖处带有铰链的人工肢体，以重现自然的步态。几十年后，第二次世界大战带来了更多的假肢创新。工程科学、材料科学，这些在30年代和40年代都在酝酿，它们
really take off during and after World War II in the Soviet Union and the US and Britain, the development of what we think of as prosthetic science, they really become industries. In the United States, a team of military personnel, engineers, and prosthetists came together at the request of the Surgeon General of the Army to form the Committee on prosthetics, engineers, and prosthetists came together at the request of the surgeon general of the army to form the committee on prosthetics, research, and development. They wanted to figure out how to actually develop prosthetics into a proper field of medicine. And the biggest challenge was developing a good artificial hand. prosthetic legs are simpler to design and users tend to have higher satisfaction rates with them,
在二战期间及之后在苏联、美国和英国真正起飞，我们所认为的假肢科学的发展，它们真正成为了产业。在美国，应陆军军医总监的要求，由军事人员、工程师和假肢矫形师组成的团队聚集在一起，成立了假肢、研究与开发委员会。他们想弄清楚如何真正将假肢发展成为一个正规的医学领域。而最大的挑战是开发出一只好的人工手。假肢腿的设计更简单，用户对它们的满意度往往更高，
but creating a hand that incorporated robotics wasn't possible until well into the Cold War. The 60s and 70s, there are all of these engineering sciences that develop between let's say the military and like MIT or Northwestern. So instead of just developing NAPm, they're also developing technologies that allow you to use batteries for what are called myoelectric arms. A myoelectric arm is a battery-powered prosthesis that can be controlled by movements on the residual limb.
但直到冷战时期，制造出一只结合了机器人技术的手才成为可能。60年代和70年代，在军队与麻省理工学院或西北大学之间发展出了所有这些工程科学。所以，他们不仅在开发凝固汽油弹，还在开发允许你使用电池来驱动所谓的“肌电手臂”的技术。肌电手臂是一种电池驱动的假肢，可以通过残肢上的动作来控制。
In the early 1990s, Brate actually became one of the youngest children in the country to get one. I wasn't the first, but I was part of one of the earliest cohorts of babies, basically, using myoelectric hands. At the time, these myoelectric hands were stated the art compared to anything else on the market. But all that Brit's hand could really do was pinch open and shut.
在90年代初，布里特实际上成为了全国最早使用这种假肢的孩子之一。我不是第一个，但我基本上是第一批使用肌电手婴儿中的一员。当时，与市场上任何其他产品相比，这些肌电手都是最先进的。但布里特的手实际上只能做捏合和张开的动作。
She worked with these devices all the way through middle school. And it was a real crowd-leaser in the Zehunc grain. It was like a party trick in middle school where you're like, hey, I can crush a can. And you know, that's fun for a while. But as Brit got older, she realized just how useless her myoelectric hand really was. If you think about it, how many tasks in your day, do you need a slow-moving, grinding-clicking thing that will grip in a single motion, more like a pinch?
她在整个中学期间都使用这些设备。这在当时是一个真正的“人群取悦者”。在中学里，这就像是一个派对戏法，你会说，“嘿，我可以捏碎一个罐子”。你知道，这很有趣，但持续不了多久。但随着布里特长大，她意识到她的肌电手实际上是多么无用。如果你想一想，你一天中有多少任务需要一个移动缓慢、发出咔哒声、只能以单一动作（更像是捏合）抓握的东西？
It couldn't even grab a piece of paper. It would just slide right through. And by the time she got into high school, she was pretty over it. This thing doesn't help me. It's heavy, and I'm just going to quit. So I went exclusively to passive arms after that. A passive prosthesis, also called a cosmetic prosthesis,
它甚至抓不住一张纸。纸会直接滑过去。到了高中时，她已经受够了。“这东西对我没帮助。它很重，我打算放弃了。”所以在那之后，我完全改用了被动式假肢。被动式假肢，也称为美容假肢，
is a device that closely resembles a quote-unquote natural limb. It doesn't crush any cans or get you any attention. In fact, it serves the opposite purpose to help you blend in. Something that I had deeply ingrained in me over my lifetime, that like, I needed to wear this or else people are gonna treat me differently. They're gonna look at me funny. I need to wear this so that I am undetected
是一种非常接近所谓“自然肢体”的设备。它不会捏碎任何罐子，也不会为你吸引任何注意力。事实上，它的作用恰恰相反，是为了帮助你融入人群。这是我一生中根深蒂固的东西，就像是，我需要戴上它，否则人们会以不同的方式对待我。他们会用奇怪的眼光看我。我需要戴上它，这样我就不会被发现，
and that I can conform and that my life runs smoother. After her bad experience with the myelectric arm, she had no interest in dabbling in advanced prosthetics anymore. She was resigned to just staying undetected. That is, until a few years ago, when her prosthetist reached out. They got in touch with me, and they said, you know, there's been a lot of changes
这样我就可以顺从，我的生活也会更顺畅。在经历了肌电手臂的糟糕体验后，她对涉足高级假肢再也没有兴趣了。她甘愿保持“不被发现”的状态。直到几年前，她的假肢矫形师联系了她。“他们联系了我，说，你知道，假肢手臂技术已经有了很多变化。”
in prosthetic arm technology. Things are a lot more sophisticated. In the years since Brit stopped using powered devices, innovation in the field had gone into hyperdrive. These new advancements in prosthetics were driven in the early 2000s by a renewed sense of government responsibility to compensate for the inadequacies of the American health care system.
事情变得复杂多了。在布里特停止使用动力设备后的几年里，该领域的创新进入了超速状态。这些假肢的新进展在21世纪初受到了一种重新燃起的政府责任感的推动，旨在弥补美国医疗体系的不足。
No, I'm just kidding. It was because of the military again. The Iraq war was a really big turning point in prosthetics in the US, but also in parts of Europe. In 2006, DARPA launched the Revolutionizing Prosthetics program in response to the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan. They wanted to address the shortcomings of available prosthetics program in response to the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan. They wanted to address the shortcomings of available prosthetics for veterans with amputations
不，我开玩笑的。还是因为军队。伊拉克战争是美国乃至欧洲部分地区假肢领域的一个非常大的转折点。2006年，DARPA（美国国防高级研究计划局）发起了“假肢革命”计划，以应对伊拉克和阿富汗的战争。他们想要解决现有假肢的缺陷，为截肢的退伍军人提供更好的选择，
by building the ultimate powered hand that would be sleeker and multi-articulating, meaning the individual digits on the hand could move and form different grip patterns. And this time around, they wanted these new high-tech prosthetics to look bionic. The goal 30, 40 years ago in prosthetics was to make things look realistic and to be able to pass. David Sirlin again. But now you do tend to see
通过制造终极动力手，使其更时尚、多关节化，这意味着手上的各个手指可以移动并形成不同的抓握模式。这一次，他们希望这些新的高科技假肢看起来像仿生产品。大卫·瑟林再次说道：“30、40年前，假肢的目标是让它们看起来逼真，能够以假乱真。”但现在你确实倾向于看到
prosthetics that are the last thing that they're interested in doing is looking like the quinoaquat real thing. They will have articulated fingers or articulated joints, but they're not looking to mimic the way that the human flesh colored elbow joint or knee joint or finger joints look. In fact, what they look more like are robots out of Star Trek or Star Wars. We'd seen articulating bionic limbs
假肢，它们最不感兴趣的就是看起来像所谓的“真实的东西”。它们会有铰接的手指或铰接的关节，但它们并不寻求模仿人类肉色肘关节、膝关节或指关节的样子。事实上，它们看起来更像是《星际迷航》或《星球大战》里的机器人。几十年来，我们在电影和漫画书中看到了铰接式仿生肢体，
in movies and comic books for decades. And now it seemed like real world prosthetics were finally getting closer to our sci-fi dreams. Like, I mean, we've always had sci-fi movies be the standard for what we want in the future, right? And there's just like this turn in like, okay, what's possible? We can rebuild it. We have the technology.
而现在，现实世界中的假肢似乎终于越来越接近我们的科幻梦想了。就像，我的意思是，科幻电影一直是我们在未来想要的标准，对吧？而且这就像是一个转折点，关于“什么是有可能的？”我们可以重建它。我们拥有这项技术。
And there seem to be kind of like a weird alignment in the early 2000s, where what was potentially possible technologically started to line up more with like this vision of what is gonna be attainable. It's gonna help a grip. And that is like perfectly replaceable prosthetic limbs. You have a metal arm? That is awesome dude.
在21世纪初，似乎出现了一种奇怪的契合，即技术上潜在的可能性开始与这种“什么将是可以实现的”愿景更加一致。它将有助于抓握。那就是完美可替换的假肢。你有一只金属手臂？那太酷了，伙计。
So in 2018, tempted by all of these new advances in the technology, Britt decided to get her first myoelectric prosthesis in over 15 years. There was a lot of anticipation that was being built amongst my friends and myself for what at the time seemed like the coolest, most life-changing, cutting-edge prosthetic arm that I would receive in my life? And I thought it was kind of time to do something really dumb and silly about it.
所以，在2018年，受到所有这些新技术进步的诱惑，布里特决定在15年来首次获得她的第一个肌电假肢。我和我的朋友们都非常期待，因为在当时，这看起来是我一生中收到的最酷、最能改变生活、最尖端的假肢手臂。我觉得是时候为此做点真正愚蠢和傻气的事情了。
Like throw an arm party. She's gonna be in this place, please speed it. And this is not gonna work. Here we go, yeah, yeah, yeah. You come back, yeah. Come back. She was embracing her cyborg future, and it looked awesome. People were like, sh**.
比如举办一场“手臂派对”。她会出现在这个地方，请加速。这招行不通。开始了，耶，耶，耶。你回来，耶。回来。她正在拥抱她的赛博格未来，看起来棒极了。人们就像是，天哪。
Like when I'm wearing a dress, I had like a little heel, and then there's this like stormtrooper, like very aggressive looking kind of militaristic hand. Like look badass. People love it. They just, they want to see tricks. They want to see like how it moves. It was, I mean, like, I like the attention. And it felt like middle school again. But a lot like when she was in middle school, Brick quickly realized that this high tech piece of machinery
就像我穿裙子的时候，我穿了一双小高跟鞋，然后还有这只看起来非常激进、带有军国主义色彩的“冲锋队员”式的手。看起来很酷。人们喜欢它。他们只是，他们想看戏法。他们想看它是如何移动的。我的意思是，我喜欢这种关注。这感觉就像回到了中学。但就像她在中学时一样，布里特很快意识到这件高科技机械
wasn't all that it was hyped up to be. It was heavy. It was hot. It was incredibly uncomfortable. But Brick still practiced with it every day, putting it on and trying to get her body used to the discomfort. Maybe it's sort of like breaking in leather heels or something or like, I liked the way this looks
并没有被吹捧的那么好。它很重。它很热。它非常不舒服。但布里特仍然每天练习，戴上它，试图让她的身体适应这种不适。也许这有点像穿皮质高跟鞋之类的，或者就像，“我喜欢它的外观，
and I think I will look sexy. But right now it's pain, and you have to endure the pain. And the pain wasn't really worth it. The point of assistive technology like prosthetic devices is to assist, but there are a lot of things this multi-articulating hand couldn't do, simple things, like turning a doorknob. So this thing cannot open a doorknob, turning it. Because that's a forearm rotation,
我觉得我会看起来很性感”。但现在它是痛苦的，你必须忍受这种痛苦。而这种痛苦并不值得。像假肢这样的辅助技术的目的是辅助，但这只多关节手有很多事情做不到，比如简单的动作，像转动门把手。所以这东西没法转动门把手。因为那需要前臂旋转，
that's a wrist rotation, that's not gonna happen. And it wasn't like she could just make the hand do whatever she wanted. She was limited to only the grips that were pre-programmed on the device. If you wanna do like a thumbs up and then go straight to like a hang 10, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how, how up and then go straight to like a hang 10, how, how I go.
那是手腕旋转，那是不可能发生的。而且并不是说她可以让手随心所欲地做任何动作。她仅限于设备上预编程的抓握模式。如果你想做一个大拇指朝上的手势，然后直接变成“挂10”的手势，怎么，怎么，怎么……
No, no. So it is multi-articulating, but it is not individually articulating. Like there are presets and that's it. I can't like decide to use the middle finger. Oh, that's not even an option? No. Okay. And also it's proprietary.
不，不。所以它是多关节的，但不是独立关节的。就像有预设，仅此而已。我不能决定使用中指。哦，那甚至不是一个选项？不。好吧。而且它还是专有的。
So if you would like to change the grip patterns, you must make an appointment with your prosthetist. There were actually only a few tasks that her bionic hand was helpful for, like holding an umbrella in one hand and a cell phone in the other at the same time. Which now is not a problem because I live in the Bay Area and it never rains. And it was great for operating a potato ricer on Thanksgiving. Other than that, her $70,000 bionic hand has been kind of a bust.
所以如果你想改变抓握模式，你必须和你的假肢矫形师预约。实际上，她的仿生手能帮上忙的任务只有几个，比如一只手拿着雨伞，另一只手同时拿着手机。这现在不是问题了，因为我住在湾区，那里从不下雨。而且它在感恩节操作土豆压泥器时非常棒。除此之外，她那7万美元的仿生手有点失败。
So I made $70,000 Thanksgiving mashed potatoes. Is it worth it? No. Which brings up another issue with advanced prosthetics. How absurdly expensive they are. Brit was lucky enough to have really good insurance which paid for the bulk of the price, but a complex, myoelectric arm can cost anywhere from 20,000 to 100,000 dollars.
所以我做了7万美元的感恩节土豆泥。值得吗？不。这就引出了高级假肢的另一个问题。它们贵得离谱。布里特很幸运，有很好的保险，支付了大部分费用，但一个复杂的肌电手臂价格可能在2万到10万美元之间。
And even if you have good insurance, it can be a battle to get insurance companies to pay for even the most basic types of prosthetics, let alone the experimental high tech kinds. But despite the high financial costs and all the functionality issues, Brits says a lot of people still choose these types of advanced prosthetics over low tech options in order to meet other people's expectations. It seems like there's a little bit of an overbearing expectation that like if you're missing a limb, then you need to have a cyborg arm. You need to be bionic, because that's cool.
即使你有很好的保险，让保险公司支付哪怕是最基本的假肢费用也是一场战斗，更不用说那些实验性的高科技产品了。但尽管经济成本高昂且存在所有功能问题，布里特说，很多人仍然选择这些类型的高级假肢，而不是低科技选项，以满足他人的期望。似乎有一种过度的期望，即如果你缺失了一个肢体，那么你就需要有一个赛博格手臂。你需要是仿生的，因为那很酷。
It gets you cool attention. Futuristic prosthetic technologies are exciting and draw specific type of positive attention. And for a lot of people with limb differences, this attention can seem better than the alternative. When we wear a prosthesis in public, we attract attention. But we're going to attract attention no matter what. So the person has to decide, with what are they more comfortable?
它能为你带来很酷的关注。未来派的假肢技术令人兴奋，并吸引了特定类型的积极关注。对于许多有肢体差异的人来说，这种关注似乎比另一种选择要好。当我们在公共场合佩戴假肢时，我们会吸引注意力。但无论如何我们都会吸引注意力。所以这个人必须决定，他们对什么更感到舒适？
This is Debbie Latour. She's an occupational therapist and does educational consulting for prosthetics design. Debbie also has a congenital limb difference, and occasionally uses a powered hand. She actually really likes hers. It's invaluable for doing things like typing and I'm a university professor.
这是黛比·拉图尔。她是一名职业治疗师，并为假肢设计提供教育咨询。黛比也有先天性肢体差异，偶尔会使用动力手。她实际上非常喜欢她的假肢。它在打字等方面非常宝贵，而且我是一名大学教授。
I do a lot of bime annual activities. And not using her prosthetic arm can come with its own problems. If you've ever tried to push a grocery cart with one arm, I would challenge you to do it and be prepared to knock down and display at the end of an aisle. Debbie may have a different relationship with her prosthetic hand, but she does agree with Brit that the way that high-tech limbs are viewed by people who don't have limb differences
我做很多双侧活动。而不使用她的假肢手臂可能会带来自己的问题。如果你曾经尝试过用一只手推购物车，我会挑战你去做，并准备好在过道尽头撞倒陈列品。黛比可能与她的假肢手有不同的关系，但她确实同意布里特的观点，即高科技肢体被没有肢体差异的人看待的方式
can be damaging. And a lot of that has to do with how we talk about them. Oftentimes, prosthetic technology is viewed as like the savior or the superhero type of thing that's going to give us all of these biome because it's or the superhero type of thing that's going to give us all of these biotic, because it's a biotic arm, it's going to give us superhuman capacities. But it's a process. If you spend too much time on Twitter, like me, or you watch a lot of local news, then
可能是具有破坏性的。这很大程度上与我们谈论它们的方式有关。通常，假肢技术被视为救世主或超级英雄类型的东西，它将赋予我们所有这些……因为它是一个仿生手臂，它将赋予我们超人的能力。但这是一个过程。如果你像我一样在推特上花太多时间，或者你看很多地方新闻，那么
you've probably come across a very specific type of viral video about advanced prosthetics. There feel good videos that feature a child with a limb difference, being given a bionic arm with some sort of click-bady title. Like, baby receives prosthetic arm, look at their reaction, or 10-year-old opens up 3D printed arm for the first time, see how they squeal.
你可能遇到过一种非常特定类型的关于高级假肢的病毒式视频。这些是让人感觉良好的视频，主角是一个有肢体差异的孩子，被赋予了一只仿生手臂，标题带有某种点击诱饵。比如，“婴儿收到假肢手臂，看他们的反应”，或者“10岁孩子第一次打开3D打印手臂，看他们如何尖叫”。
In 2012, a disability rights activist named Stella Young coined a phrase for exactly this type of video, inspiration porn. She specifically used the word porn because she sees it as the objectification of one group for the benefit of another. The media has always been about prosthetics being like savior technologies
2012年，一位名叫斯特拉·杨的残疾人权利活动家为这类视频创造了一个词：励志色情（inspiration porn）。她特别使用了“色情”这个词，因为她认为这是为了一个群体的利益而将另一个群体客体化。媒体一直把假肢描述为救世主技术，
and like feel good fluff pieces. Look at this disabled kid or look at this disabled adult and now their life is better because of this tech. You see this a lot in reaction videos of babies hearing for the first time after receiving a cochlear implant, too. These stories give people an unrealistic expectation of what advanced prosthetic devices can actually do for users.
以及让人感觉良好的煽情文章。看看这个残疾孩子，或者看看这个残疾成年人，现在他们的生活因为这项技术而变得更好了。你在婴儿在接受人工耳蜗后第一次听到声音的反应视频中也经常看到这种情况。这些故事给了人们关于高级假肢设备实际上能为用户做什么的不切实际的期望。
And they show a very narrow version of what thriving looks like for people with a disability. All those inspiration stories, all of those pity stories, all of those technology rescue stories, all of those are a way I think for us to just cognitively contain difference. And we can't imagine that difference actually might be a form of flourishing. This is Sarah Hendren. She teaches design and fine arts at Oling College of Engineering. She is not a fan of these types of videos either. They teach us that the solution to someone having a limb difference is to build them a
它们展示了一个非常狭隘的关于残疾人如何“茁壮成长”的版本。所有那些励志故事，所有那些同情故事，所有那些技术拯救故事，我认为所有这些都是我们认知上遏制差异的一种方式。我们无法想象差异实际上可能是一种繁荣的形式。这是莎拉·亨德伦。她在奥林工程学院教授设计和美术。她也不是这些类型视频的粉丝。它们教导我们，解决某人肢体差异的方法是为他们制造一个
better hand. Or the solution to disability in general is to quote, fix a body. The next time we meet somebody who's blind, the next time we accompany our aging grandparent to the theater, the next time, you know, we encounter a person with Downsenderm on the street, we can only think of, oh, where's the cyborg rescue for this person? You know, like, where is the, um, the kind of soft piano music swelling in the background? You know, that kind of narrative. And that is a flattened way of seeing the world.
更好的手。或者解决残疾的一般方法是“修复”身体。下次我们遇到盲人时，下次我们陪同年迈的祖父母去剧院时，下次我们遇到唐氏综合症患者时，我们只能想到，“哦，这个人的赛博格救星在哪里？”你知道，就像，背景中那种柔和的钢琴音乐在哪里响起？你知道，那种叙事。那是一种扁平化的看待世界的方式。
It's not hard for people interested in building a system tech to get caught up in this narrative too. Hendren teaches a lot of engineering students. And she worries that this type of narrow representation can enforce the idea that high tech solutions are the only ones that matter. I say this with love.
对于有兴趣构建辅助技术的人来说，陷入这种叙事并不难。亨德伦教了很多工程系学生。她担心这种狭隘的代表性会强化这样一种观念，即高科技解决方案是唯一重要的。我带着爱说这一点。
It is a kind of slam dunk for like a young person who was interested in robotics who broadly wants to do good in the world high-tech prosthetic lens looks like you know the center of that venn diagram, but it can obscure then What is the technology could really be? It feels like the temptation for designers is to try to create an amazing new technology that can erase a person's disability When maybe the better challenge is to try to design a world that can accommodate people with different types of bodies and different sets of abilities.
对于一个对机器人技术感兴趣、想在世界上做好事的年轻人来说，这是一种“扣篮式”的成功。高科技假肢看起来像是那个维恩图的中心，但它可能会掩盖技术真正可能是什么。对于设计师来说，诱惑似乎是试图创造一种可以消除一个人残疾的惊人新技术，而更好的挑战也许是尝试设计一个能够容纳具有不同身体类型和不同能力的人的世界。
We've kind of chosen the messier way, which is like trying to make every person who is not quote unquote, whole, whole again. When we could make kitchen counters or cars more accessible to begin with that are more adaptable. In Brits case, instead of selling her a $70,000 arm that makes it easier for her to use a potato ricer, maybe we could design a potato ricer that's a little easier for someone with a different type of body to operate. A lot of people with limb differences can do tasks better with no prosthesis at all because
我们选择了一种更混乱的方式，即试图让每一个不是所谓的“完整”的人再次变得“完整”。而我们本可以从一开始就让厨房台面或汽车更易于使用，更具适应性。在布里特的案例中，与其卖给她一个7万美元的手臂让她更容易使用土豆压泥器，也许我们可以设计一个对身体类型不同的人来说更容易操作的土豆压泥器。许多有肢体差异的人在完全不使用假肢的情况下可以更好地完成任务，因为
they've developed their own adaptations. And for many others, the lower-tech options are actually a lot more functional. There are things like split hook prosthesis, which are super reliable because they have no electronic components and don't attempt to resemble a hand at all. There are over 2 million people in the United States living with a limb difference, and every single one of those experiences is different. Satisfaction with a prosthetic device can depend on
他们发展出了自己的适应方式。对于许多其他人来说，低科技选项实际上功能性更强。有一些东西，比如分体钩假肢，它们非常可靠，因为它们没有电子元件，也不试图模仿手。美国有超过200万人患有肢体差异，每一个人的经历都是不同的。对假肢设备的满意度取决于
which limb is affected, or how many limbs are affected, you can depend on how high or low an amputation might be, or whether or not you were born with it. There's no such thing as a one-size-fits-all solution to assistive tech, and we need to listen to what people actually need in order to navigate the world. I want to make space for like, critiquing these things, because otherwise then we just have to be grateful all the time for like, whatever gets invented. These days, Brit doesn't use her high-tech,
哪个肢体受到影响，或者有多少肢体受到影响，取决于截肢的高低，或者你是否天生如此。辅助技术没有“一刀切”的解决方案，我们需要倾听人们为了在世界上航行真正需要什么。我想留出空间来批判这些东西，因为否则我们就必须一直对发明出来的任何东西心存感激。这些天，布里特不使用她的高科技
bionic arm and doesn't even wear a cosmetic prosthesis anymore. But a couple of times a week, she uses an activity-specific device, which is a type of prosthetic socket with swappable attachments for things like exercising. It doesn't try to resemble a natural hand at all, and is much simpler than her bionic hand. She has a clamp attachment, so she can do kettlebell swings, and another called a mushroom that she uses to do balanced push-ups. It's called that because it looks like a mushroom.
仿生手臂，甚至不再佩戴美容假肢。但每周有几次，她会使用一种特定活动的设备，这是一种带有可更换附件的假肢接受腔，用于锻炼等事情。它根本不试图模仿自然手，而且比她的仿生手简单得多。她有一个夹具附件，所以她可以做壶铃摆动，还有一个叫“蘑菇”的附件，她用它来做平衡俯卧撑。它之所以叫这个名字，是因为它看起来像一个蘑菇。
And it's not like Brit is anti-technology. Actually, she's surprisingly optimistic about it. I do think that the technology will improve. I do think that there will be better options, and maybe in my lifetime, I'll get another arm that will help me do the potato ricing a little bit better. But in the meantime, she's not gonna just wait around for the perfect arm to get invented.
而且布里特并不是反技术的。事实上，她对此出奇地乐观。“我确实认为技术会进步。我确实认为会有更好的选择，也许在我有生之年，我会得到另一只手臂，帮助我把土豆压泥做得更好一点。”但与此同时，她不会只是坐等完美的手臂被发明出来。
She'll keep using her mushroom and her kettlebell clamp and sometimes no prosthesis at all. And she'll continue using all the strategies she's developed to navigate a world that wasn't built for her. The story was produced by Vivian Leigh and edited by Chris Baroube and Emmett Fitzgerald. When we come back, we have a story about how the world is not actually designed for you. It was designed for the average person. Your world has not been designed for you. In large part, it has been designed for the average person. Throughout your education, you've been given standardized tests and been graded by how
她会继续使用她的“蘑菇”和壶铃夹具，有时甚至完全不使用假肢。她将继续使用她开发的所有策略来驾驭一个并非为她而建的世界。这个故事由薇薇安·勒制作，由克里斯·巴鲁贝和埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑。当我们回来时，我们将讲述一个关于世界实际上不是为你设计的故事。它是为普通人设计的。你的世界不是为你设计的。在很大程度上，它是为普通人设计的。在你的整个教育过程中，你参加过标准化考试，并根据你的表现来评分
well you perform compared to the average. Building codes, churns rates, dow Jones, all these measurements are based around the concept of an average. And it's okay, we know you're not average. You're really special. Ah, thanks, Avery Trouffman. Well, I mean it, you're not average. And it's okay, we know you're not average. You're really special. Ah, thanks, Avery Trouffman. Well, I mean it, you're not average. No one is, not completely.
与平均水平相比。建筑规范、流失率、道琼斯指数，所有这些衡量标准都是基于平均值的概念。没关系，我们知道你不是平均水平。你真的很特别。啊，谢谢，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。嗯，我是认真的，你不是平均水平。没关系，我们知道你不是平均水平。你真的很特别。啊，谢谢，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。嗯，我是认真的，你不是平均水平。没有人是，不完全是。
But the concept of average affects us all. Everything seemed to be based around this reference point of average. And obviously everything about society is built this way, but I had never really thought of it until I dug into this new science lab part of. This is Todd Rose. My name is Todd Rose. I am the director of the My & Brain Education program at the Harvard Graduate School of Education. He's also the author of the book The End of Average. But to get to that, first we have to start with the beginning of average,
但平均值的概念影响着我们所有人。一切似乎都基于这个平均值的参考点。显然，社会的方方面面都是这样构建的，但在我深入研究这个新的科学实验室部分之前，我从未真正想过这一点。这是托德·罗斯。我的名字是托德·罗斯。我是哈佛大学教育研究生院“思维与大脑教育”项目的负责人。他也是《平均值的终结》一书的作者。但要达到这一点，首先我们必须从平均值的起源开始，
because it wasn't always a thing. The concept of average, as we know it, was pioneered by a Belgian mathematician and astronomer named Adolf Ketalai. So Ketalai is the person who actually coins the term the average man. And he is, in like the 1830s, he is actually an astronomer in Belgium. Today the way that most people get a handle on any set of numbers is to calculate the average. But in Ketalai's time, astronomers were some of the only people who did this. Basically, averages were a way to compensate for the imprecise tools that astronomers were
因为它并不总是一个东西。我们所知的平均值概念是由一位名叫阿道夫·凯特勒的比利时数学家和天文学家开创的。所以凯特勒是真正创造了“平均人”这个词的人。在1830年代，他实际上是比利时的一名天文学家。今天，大多数人处理任何一组数字的方法是计算平均值。但在凯特勒的时代，天文学家是仅有的做这件事的人之一。基本上，平均值是一种补偿天文学家所使用的不精确工具的方法，
working with in 1830. If you were trying to time the movement of Saturn, you would etch little scratches on your glass of your telescope, and as soon as it crossed one you'd start counting and you'd stop counting after it crossed the other and then you'd write it down but you can imagine, like even if you're off by half a second it's gonna introduce a lot of error. And so they realized if they wanted to make sense of taming the heavens they needed more precision in their estimates. And they realized that if you had say ten measurements and they were all slightly different, if you added them together and divided them by 10, you'd get a better approximation of
他们在1830年工作时。如果你试图计时土星的运动，你会在望远镜的玻璃上刻下小划痕，一旦它穿过一个，你就开始计数，穿过另一个后停止计数，然后把它写下来，但你可以想象，即使你误差了半秒，也会引入很多误差。所以他们意识到，如果他们想理解如何驯服天空，他们需要在估计中更精确。他们意识到，如果你有十个测量值，它们都略有不同，如果你把它们加在一起除以10，你就会得到一个更好的近似值，
the true measurement. If you just average together our measurements, you're way more likely to be closer to the truth, right? And you end up getting kind of a bell curve of measurement errors. KELOLAY was the first to take this tool of astronomers and apply it to people. In the early 1840s, KELOLAY finds a data set of the chest measurements of 5,738 Scottish soldiers. KELOLAY added together each of the measurements and divided it by the total sum of the soldiers, and that result, 39 and 3-quarters inches, was one of the very first times a scientist had calculated the
真实的测量值。如果你只是把我们的测量值平均在一起，你更有可能接近真相，对吧？你最终会得到一个测量误差的钟形曲线。凯特勒是第一个将天文学家的这个工具应用到人身上的人。在1840年代初，凯特勒找到了5738名苏格兰士兵的胸围测量数据集。凯特勒将每个测量值加在一起，除以士兵的总数，结果是39又3/4英寸，这是科学家第一次计算出
average size of a human feature. But he brings with it the idea of truth that the average chest size is true and that all the individuals are like error that nature is striving for the average soldier. This means the average measurement is the true measurement, the platonic ideal, the perfect Scottish soldier, as a chest, that is 39 and 3 ¼ inches according to Ketalai. So he's the one that decides not only his average mathematically useful, it's morally the way to think about people.
人类特征的平均尺寸。但他随之带来了“真理”的概念，即平均胸围是真实的，而所有个体都是“误差”，自然界正在努力追求平均士兵。这意味着平均测量值是真实的测量值，是柏拉图式的理想，完美的苏格兰士兵，胸围是39又3/4英寸，根据凯特勒的说法。所以他是那个决定了平均值不仅在数学上有用，而且在道德上也是思考人的方式的人。
And so he basically finds averages anywhere he can possibly find them. And he just has like a field day. He measures all kinds of other people and averages them. He creates something called the Ketalai index for measuring ratios of average height and average weight. And actually we still use it today. Just now it's called the body mass index or BMI. Ketalai would say if you talked about height, everyone, if they were optimally fed, if they were under the same environmental conditions would have been average. So his view was that what you're striving for is the continual improvement of the average of the group. And it wasn't all just physical. Ketaleg comes through various data sets for marriages,
所以他基本上在任何能找到的地方寻找平均值。他简直玩疯了。他测量了各种其他人并将他们平均化。他创造了一种叫做“凯特勒指数”的东西，用于测量平均身高和平均体重的比例。事实上，我们今天仍然在使用它。只是现在它被称为身体质量指数或BMI。凯特勒会说，如果你谈论身高，每个人，如果他们得到最佳喂养，如果他们在相同的环境条件下，都会是平均水平。所以他的观点是，你所追求的是群体平均水平的持续改善。而且这不仅仅是身体上的。凯特勒查看了各种婚姻、
murders, and suicides, and calculates the averages for them. He figures out there's such a thing as a normal suicide rate, which is really, really bizarre at the time, almost scandalous. Nowadays, when we're so used to the stability of big, massive amounts of data, that it's hard to put yourself in their shoes, but like, back then, they really thought that something, like, say, suicide was such a personal decision that there couldn't possibly be any pattern there. But suddenly there were patterns of body size, of intelligence, of birth, of death. People became
谋杀和自杀的数据集，并计算了它们的平均值。他发现存在所谓的“正常自杀率”，这在当时非常非常离奇，几乎是丑闻。如今，当我们习惯了大量数据的稳定性时，很难设身处地为他们着想，但在当时，他们真的认为像自杀这样的事情是一个如此私人的决定，不可能有任何模式。但突然间，出现了体型、智力、出生、死亡的模式。人们变成了
statistics. Their behavior starts to become predictable. Suddenly human life went by the numbers. So obviously, the first interpretation is, well, wait a minute, maybe there's no free will, right? Maybe there's laws of society just like there's laws of physics. And so that kick started a whole bunch of people like Karl Marx, who loved Ketalai. And Ketalai becomes a huge star. In his time, Ketalai was up there with the likes of Sir Isaac Newton. His science of averages was this remarkable cutting edgeway to assess the health, wellness, and progress of populations.
统计数据。他们的行为开始变得可预测。突然间，人类生活按数字运行。所以显然，第一个解释是，好吧，等一下，也许没有自由意志，对吧？也许社会有规律，就像物理学有规律一样。所以这激发了一大批人，比如卡尔·马克思，他很喜欢凯特勒。凯特勒成为了一个巨大的明星。在他的时代，凯特勒与艾萨克·牛顿爵士等人齐名。他的平均值科学是一种评估人口健康、福祉和进步的非凡尖端方式。
He's really active in the 1820s, 1830s, 1840s, all the way into the 50s and 60s. And the 1860s brings us to the US Civil War, and to another superfan of Ketale's science of averages, Abraham Lincoln. When the Civil War is going in the North, Lincoln actually decides they're kind of getting their butt kicked, frankly.
他在1820年代、1830年代、1840年代一直到50年代和60年代都非常活跃。1860年代把我们带到了美国内战，也带到了凯特勒平均值科学的另一个超级粉丝，亚伯拉罕·林肯。当内战在北方进行时，林肯实际上决定，坦率地说，他们有点被打得屁滚尿流。
In large part because this war had gotten so huge and unwieldy, Lincoln doesn't really have a handle on the Northern Army. And he's like, look, we don't even know who our soldiers are. We don't know how well fed they are. We don't know what kind of armor they need. We don't know anything about them. Lincoln decided that the Union Army needed more information about its soldiers in order to best distribute resources.
在很大程度上是因为这场战争变得如此巨大和笨重，林肯并没有真正掌握北方军队的情况。他说：“看，我们甚至不知道我们的士兵是谁。我们不知道他们吃得怎么样。我们不知道他们需要什么样的盔甲。我们对他们一无所知。”林肯决定，联邦军队需要更多关于其士兵的信息，以便最好地分配资源。
So he ordered this enormous study to assess the Union Army physically, medically, and mentally. And then in explicit obedience to Ketalai's new science, averages were calculated and reported. They actually say, basically, we're following the father of this new field, Kentela. These freshly calculated averages informed the distributions of food rations and the design of weapons. For example, if you were going to create muskets, well, how far is the trigger? And you could actually calculate average reach for soldier. This also affected military uniforms, which used to be all custom-sum, but in the Civil War, so many people had to be outfitted that custom uniforms would be impossibly expensive,
所以他下令进行这项巨大的研究，从身体、医学和心理上评估联邦军队。然后，在明确服从凯特勒的新科学的情况下，计算并报告了平均值。他们实际上说，基本上，我们正在追随这个新领域的父亲，凯特勒。这些新计算出的平均值告知了食物配给的分配和武器的设计。例如，如果你要制造火枪，那么扳机有多远？你可以计算士兵的平均触及范围。这也影响了军服，军服过去都是定制的，但在内战中，必须装备的人太多了，定制军服将贵得不可思议，
so the uniforms had to be mass-produced. But they couldn't be just all one big floppy size. And so now they're realizing, oh, well, you know, if we break it into subtypes, like there's a large, and this is what we mean by, you it. This big of a torso, this broad of shoulders, small, medium, large, that's gonna carry over into the way they think about the mass production of clothing. Yep, the size of the small, medium, and large,
所以制服必须大规模生产。但它们不能只是一个大而松垮的尺码。于是他们现在意识到，哦，你知道，如果我们把它分成子类型，比如有大号，这就是我们所说的，你懂的。躯干这么大，肩膀这么宽，小号、中号、大号，这会延续到他们对服装大规模生产的思考方式中。是的，小号、中号和大号的尺寸，
which might be on your t-shirt tag, those came out of this massive civil war study. So you can thank Ketalai and Lincoln for that. This study in the civil war was the basis for the American military's long-standing philosophy of standardized average-based design. And that's gonna become the fundamental design philosophy from the Civil War forward.
这可能出现在你的T恤标签上，它们源于这项大规模的内战研究。所以你可以为此感谢凯塔莱和林肯。这项内战研究是美国军队长期以来基于平均值的标准化设计理念的基础。这将成为从内战开始的基本设计理念。
So in 1926, when the army was designing its first ever fighter plane cockpit, engineers measured the physical dimensions of hundreds of male pilots and used this data to standardize cockpit dimensions. Of course, the possibility of female pilots was never considered. Of course. The size and shape of the seat, the distance to the pedals and the stick, the height of
所以在1926年，当军队设计其有史以来第一架战斗机驾驶舱时，工程师们测量了数百名男性飞行员的身体尺寸，并利用这些数据来标准化驾驶舱尺寸。当然，女性飞行员的可能性从未被考虑过。当然。座椅的大小和形状，到踏板和操纵杆的距离，挡风玻璃的高度，
the windshield, even the shape of the flight helmets were all made to conform to the average 1920s male pilot, which changed the way the pilots were selected. You basically then select people that fit into that and then exclude people that don't. And this cockpit design worked, okay, up to World War II. What happened was though, is that in World War II, it became an Air Force War, right? That was the first time when the Air Force would be the determinant of who was gonna win the war.
甚至飞行头盔的形状，都是为了符合1920年代的平均男性飞行员而制造的，这改变了飞行员的选择方式。你基本上是选择适合这些标准的人，然后排除不适合的人。这种驾驶舱设计在二战前还可以。但发生的情况是，在二战中，这变成了一场空军战争，对吧？那是空军第一次成为决定战争胜负的关键。
And we absolutely ran out of pilots. The government recruited hundreds of new pilots and expanded military aviation. There's been a bunch of money on fancy new planes. Although the cockpits were still designed for the average 1920s male pilot. And this new big bad military force was going to fly the fastest and the highest and be the best. But that's not what happened. They actually had a pretty massive decline in performance, including just a rash of deaths. Pilots were dying all the time.
我们彻底耗尽了飞行员。政府招募了数百名新飞行员并扩大了军事航空。在昂贵的新飞机上投入了大量资金。尽管驾驶舱仍然是为1920年代的平均男性飞行员设计的。这支强大的新军事力量本应飞得最快、最高，成为最棒的。但事实并非如此。他们的表现实际上出现了巨大的下滑，包括一系列的死亡事件。飞行员一直在死亡。
Even after the war ended, just in training, they could not control their planes. It became kind of part of the culture of the Air Force, where hey, it's just really dangerous to fly. No one knew what was going on. Some people thought, well, these ain't propeller planes anymore. Maybe these new pilots just can't deal with the new aviation technology. And then they were like, well, maybe you got to train them better and they did their better training programs, and that didn't work.
即使在战争结束后，仅仅是在训练中，他们也无法控制自己的飞机。这成了空军文化的一部分，嘿，飞行真的很危险。没人知道发生了什么。有些人认为，好吧，这些不再是螺旋桨飞机了。也许这些新飞行员只是无法应对新的航空技术。然后他们说，好吧，也许你需要更好地训练他们，他们确实进行了更好的训练计划，但这并没有奏效。
After blaming the pilots, the training programs, and the technology, it finally don'ts on them. What if it's the cockpit? Maybe it doesn't fit us anymore. Their first instinct is to think, we've just gotten bigger as a people, so the old average from 1922 is just too small. We're just bigger and better,
在指责飞行员、训练计划和技术之后，他们终于意识到。如果问题出在驾驶舱呢？也许它不再适合我们了。他们的第一直觉是认为，我们作为一个群体变大了，所以1922年的旧平均值太小了。我们只是变得更大、更强了，
and like, let's build a better average. So in 1950, researchers at Wright Air Force Base in Ohio were tasked with finding this new average. And one of those researchers was a man named Gilbert S. Daniels. Daniels was a Harvard graduate who had written his thesis on the average sizes of his classmates' hands. He was 23 years old, small, skinny, nerdy, not a military man at all. And he travels all over the country to different air force
所以，让我们建立一个更好的平均值。因此，在1950年，俄亥俄州赖特空军基地的研究人员被委以寻找这个新平均值的任务。其中一位研究人员是一个名叫吉尔伯特·S·丹尼尔斯的人。丹尼尔斯是哈佛大学的毕业生，他曾写过关于同学手部平均尺寸的论文。他当时23岁，瘦小、书呆子气，根本不是军人。他前往全国各地的不同空军
bases, and his job is to take these tape measures and just measure like 147 different dimensions of body size. It's got to be the most tedious job ever. And as Daniels is traveling around from base to base measuring thousands of airmen, he's realizing this incredible variability from person to person, even within this limited demographic of young men. As he was measuring hands and legs and wastes and foreheads, Daniels kept asking himself,
基地，他的工作就是拿着卷尺测量大约147种不同的身体尺寸。这一定是有史以来最枯燥的工作。当丹尼尔斯在各个基地之间奔波，测量成千上万的飞行员时，他意识到即使在这些有限的年轻人人口统计中，人与人之间也存在着令人难以置信的差异。当他测量手、腿、腰和前额时，丹尼尔斯不断问自己，
how many pilots were actually average? So he reports back. So he goes to them and says, look, I think there's a problem with the average and he says, I just want to do this side study. I want to know if we take the 10 dimensions of size that matter most for design, like say shoulder width, height chest, or conference, sleeve length, etc. How many of these pilots are actually average on all 10 of those dimensions? Daniels crunched the numbers. And of the 4,063 pilots he measured, not a single airman was close to average in all of the 10 dimensions.
到底有多少飞行员是平均水平的？所以他报告了。他去找他们说，看，我认为平均值有问题，他说，我只想做一个侧面研究。我想知道，如果我们采用对设计最重要的10个尺寸维度，比如肩宽、身高、胸围、袖长等。有多少飞行员在所有这10个维度上都是平均水平的？丹尼尔斯计算了这些数字。在他测量的4063名飞行员中，没有一个飞行员在所有10个维度上都接近平均水平。
None. Not one. And it got even worse, like if you just used three dimensions of size, less than 5% of the pilots were average on those. So he quickly realizes, like, wait, now you know the problem, if you are designing something for an average pilot, it's literally designed to fit nobody. And in this new era of jet-powered aviation,
一个都没有。情况甚至更糟，如果你只使用三个尺寸维度，不到5%的飞行员在这些维度上是平均水平。所以他很快意识到，等等，现在你知道问题所在了，如果你为平均飞行员设计东西，它实际上是为了不适合任何人而设计的。在这个喷气动力航空的新时代，
where pilots were making split-second decisions that could be life or death, it really mattered that pilots could reach what they needed to reach in a cockpit. The military is spraying into action pretty much right away. For the military to be willing to basically drop generations of design philosophy, right? Because it doesn't take them more than a few years to just be like, you can't design on average anymore. Air Force engineers and contractors designed adjustable foot pedals and adjustable helmet straps and flight suits and adjustable seats. You just can't believe that we were building planes with no adjustable seats. That's how much faith we had in
飞行员需要做出可能关乎生死的瞬间决定，飞行员能否触及驾驶舱内他们需要的东西真的很重要。军方几乎立即采取了行动。军方愿意基本上放弃几代人的设计理念，这并不容易，对吧？因为他们没花几年时间就意识到，你不能再基于平均值进行设计了。空军工程师和承包商设计了可调节的脚踏板、可调节的头盔带、飞行服和可调节的座椅。你简直不敢相信我们曾经制造过没有可调节座椅的飞机。这就是我们对
the average person. Once all the adjustable elements and other design solutions were put into place, pilot performance, soared. And of course, now we take this for granted. That equipment should fit a wide range of body sizes, instead of standardized around one average. You wouldn't buy a car that didn't have adjustable seats, right? That's just crazy.
普通人的信任程度。一旦所有可调节元件和其他设计方案到位，飞行员的表现就突飞猛进了。当然，现在我们认为这是理所当然的。设备应该适合各种体型，而不是围绕一个平均值进行标准化。你不会买一辆没有可调节座椅的汽车，对吧？那太疯狂了。
And it seeps into there pretty quickly in terms of automobiles. And then you see what's interesting is the whole idea of ergonomics. That all comes off of this period of time. We're where to jump starts the science of ergonomics, which is not just for office chairs. Well, it's really the study of work is what you could boil it down to. But it really is a matter of matching people's capacities
它很快就渗透到了汽车领域。然后你会发现有趣的是，人体工程学的整个概念。这一切都源于那个时期。它启动了人体工程学这门科学，这不仅仅是为了办公椅。嗯，你可以把它归结为对工作的研究。但这确实是一个匹配人们能力与
to the job. This is Professor Kyrissa Harris-Adamsen, Director of the UCSF UC Berkeley Ergonomics Program. It's really important not to go with the average a lot of the time. If we want to incorporate, say, a handle into something, well, we'll look up the Anthropometry data and make sure we identify the grip span that we think is best. Or if we're designing a crank
工作的问题。这是加州大学旧金山分校和加州大学伯克利分校人体工程学项目主任凯丽莎·哈里斯-亚当森教授。很多时候，不采用平均值真的很重要。如果我们想在某样东西上加入一个把手，我们会查阅人体测量数据，确保我们确定了我们认为最好的握力跨度。或者如果我们正在设计一个曲柄，
and we want it to be at a certain height, then we will go back to the Anthropometry data and figure out what makes the most sense to accommodate as much of the population as we can. Keeping in mind that in the US, most of the measurements we base our designs on still come from the US Army. That's primarily the source that we use in, say, ergonomic books or when we're designing
并且我们希望它处于一定的高度，那么我们会回到人体测量数据，找出最合理的方法来容纳尽可能多的人口。请记住，在美国，我们设计所依据的大多数测量数据仍然来自美国陆军。这是我们在人体工程学书籍中或在为工作场所进行设计时主要使用的来源。
for the workplace. And what we found is that those numbers are actually all pretty representative today, except for weight and abdominal growth. Which is part of why the world is so hard for heavier people to navigate. The military might be considered a more fit population than the rest of us. So does this mean that like military measurements affect the way our cars are designed? Absolutely.
我们发现，除了体重和腹部增长外，这些数字在今天实际上都非常有代表性。这也是为什么世界对较重的人来说很难导航的部分原因。军方可能被认为比我们其他人更健康。那么这是否意味着军事测量影响了我们汽车的设计方式？绝对是。
The measurements of our military personnel over the years affect just about everything. Military measurements are the most public and accessible. And they work okay. They're not perfect, sure, but they're getting more inclusive. They've done a really good job in a comedy more of the population, given that women are now a very vibrant part of our military force. When the military opted to design for a greater range of people, they designed for a greater
多年来我们军事人员的测量数据影响了几乎所有事物。军事测量是最公开和可获取的。它们工作得还可以。当然它们并不完美，但它们正变得更具包容性。鉴于女性现在是我们军事力量中非常有活力的一部分，他们在容纳更多人口方面做得非常好。当军方选择为更多的人群进行设计时，他们也为
range of opportunity. Take for example, Kim Campbell. She was a fighter pilot, and she flew a 810 war hog and if it's worth googling It is like the baddest looking plane you're ever gonna see That's Todd Rose again by the way helping us tell the story of Captain Campbell in 2003 Campbell was sent on a mission to assess some Marines who were trying to take a bridge in Iraq They were under heavy fire, but on her way back her plane gets shot and she loses all control She has the option to
更多的机会进行了设计。以金·坎贝尔为例。她是一名战斗机飞行员，她驾驶的是A-10雷电II攻击机，如果值得谷歌搜索的话，它是你见过的最酷的飞机。顺便说一下，那是托德·罗斯再次帮助我们讲述坎贝尔上尉的故事。2003年，坎贝尔被派去执行一项任务，评估一些试图夺取伊拉克一座桥梁的海军陆战队员。他们遭到了猛烈的炮火，但在她返回的路上，她的飞机被击中，她失去了所有控制。她可以选择
Eject right there and save her life, but then the plane spirals into Baghdad and kills a bunch of innocent people So she says like I'm not gonna do that. She stabilizes, which I don't even know how you do And she flies back and then she says look I think I can land this plane. And she lands the massive, damaged, uncontrollable plane. It's an incredible heroic feat, really unprecedented. So of course, Kim Campbell gets awards and distinctions, and she is someone who could have never been one of the best pilots in the world, had the military not changed their design philosophy.
当场弹射逃生以挽救自己的生命，但那样飞机就会盘旋坠入巴格达并杀死一群无辜的人。所以她说，我不会那样做。她稳定了飞机，我甚至不知道你是怎么做到的，然后她飞了回来，她说，看，我想我可以降落这架飞机。然后她降落了那架巨大的、受损的、无法控制的飞机。这是一项令人难以置信的英雄壮举，确实是史无前例的。所以当然，金·坎贝尔获得了奖项和荣誉，如果军方没有改变他们的设计理念，她本不可能成为世界上最好的飞行员之一。
She's the beneficiary of a cockpit that's flexibly designed. Because she's like 5'4 and rail thin and doesn't look anything remotely close to an average size pilot. When Kim gets into a cockpit, she has to put the seat all the way up and pull the pedals all the way out, but it fits. This idea of equal fit as the foundation for how we think about real opportunity in society, I think has serious consequences for the future of design. In this concept that fit makes opportunity, it's an important one for Todd, because he believes that we can design environments and equipment and even entire systems to accommodate more and more people.
她是灵活设计的驾驶舱的受益者。因为她身高5英尺4英寸，瘦得像根竹竿，看起来一点也不像平均身材的飞行员。当金进入驾驶舱时，她必须把座椅调到最高，把踏板拉到最远，但它很合适。这种平等的适配理念作为我们思考社会中真正机会的基础，我认为对设计的未来有严重的影响。在这个“适配创造机会”的概念中，这对托德来说很重要，因为他相信我们可以设计环境、设备甚至整个系统来容纳越来越多的人。
When we think about how we design environments, you know, in a lot of fields, we've made some progress around accommodating wider ranges of fields, we've made some progress around accommodating wider ranges of people, but actually in things like education, we still actually designed for this mythical average person under the assumption that if you design something that fit an average person, it would actually fit most people. By re-examining the concept of the average
当我们思考如何设计环境时，你知道，在许多领域，我们在容纳更广泛的人群方面取得了一些进展，但在教育等领域，我们仍然在为这个神话般的平均人进行设计，假设如果你设计的东西适合平均人，它实际上就会适合大多数人。通过重新审视平均值的概念
and acknowledging its limitations, we can maybe start to consider other ways of assessing and categorizing test scores or clothing sizes or wellness or happiness or worth. We can pave the way for more people who are outside of the average, because really, no one is average. That story was originally produced by 99pi Alam Avery Trouffleman back in 2016. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Vivian Le and edited by Chris Baroupe, mixed in tech production by Amita Ganatra, music by our director of sound, Sean Rial. Delaney
并承认其局限性，我们也许可以开始考虑评估和分类考试成绩、服装尺码、健康、幸福或价值的其他方式。我们可以为更多处于平均水平之外的人铺平道路，因为实际上，没有人是平均的。那个故事最初是由99pi的阿拉姆·艾弗里·特鲁夫曼在2016年制作的。本周的99% Invisible由薇薇安·勒制作，克里斯·巴鲁普编辑，阿米塔·加纳特拉进行技术制作混音，音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里亚尔创作。德莱尼·
Hall is the executive producer Kurt Colstad is the digital director, the resident includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Greg Martino from United prosthetics. Bert Young is working on a book of essays about tech, the human body, and disability. This episode was inspired by an article that she wrote for input mag, called, I Have One of the Most Advanced Prosthetic arms in the world, and I hate it. You can find a link to that on our website.
霍尔是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，常驻人员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉舍马顿、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马斯。本周特别感谢来自United Prosthetics的格雷格·马蒂诺。伯特·杨正在写一本关于科技、人体和残疾的散文集。这一集受到她为Input Mag写的一篇文章的启发，标题是《我拥有世界上最先进的假肢手臂之一，但我讨厌它》。你可以在我们的网站上找到链接。
We are a part of the Stitcher and Series XM podcast family. Now, headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussion to about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or work. We're on Instagram and read it too.
我们是Stitcher和Series XM播客家族的一部分。现在，总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我罗曼·马斯，或者@节目99PI。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。
You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Roman Mars here for Stitcher. It's powered by podcasting and serious XM. It's powered by satellites whizzing through the sky. It's available for the low low price of zero dollars. That's right, zero dollars if you act right now. That's Roman Mars for Stitcher and serious XM. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI的每一集往期节目。我是罗曼·马斯，代表Stitcher。它由播客和Serious XM提供支持。它由在天空中飞驰的卫星提供支持。它以零美元的低价提供。没错，如果你现在行动，就是零美元。那是罗曼·马斯代表Stitcher和Serious XM。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。